je me suis fait draguer par la personne
la plus lourde de france sas et
géraldine fusion non c'est pas moi ah
ouais agathe
ouais c'est le genre ça ouais encore
plus lourd que jean-michel je pense dit
rien n'allait pas c'était un c'était un
dîner organisé par des amis à moi
j'étais comment ce dîner presque parfait
[Musique]
petit ami oui c'était à 2014 ça fait
déjà quelques années
fermez votre petite amie de l'époque
vincent vincent prénom tout à fait
commun windsor et donc voilà donc je me
dis allez vas-y ce que tu sortes c'est
juste un dîner peut bien aller et aime
beaucoup il est sympa bon ok donc
l'arrivée j'avais jamais vu le make way
et donc pendant tout le dîner il
commença une fait plein de compliments
ce qui n'était pas très désagréable mais
c'était un peu un peu redondant et quand
j'habitais lunettes
voilà des choses comme ça et il me dit
j'ai très envie de t'embrasser nom qu'on
est terminée oui pendant j'en mangeais
mais lasagnes c'était horrible donc déjà
ça j'aime pas bien je vais vous révéler
la zone ouest 1 lundi et donc il ne se
débine pas je dis bon là on est en train
de manger ils poussent les plats non pas
pour se pencher comme ça pour essayé de
m'embrasser l'eyepet
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
parce que du coup il renverse le verre
d'eau non tombe sur moi donc bonjour je
suis j'en ai marre vraiment et il me dit
ah t'es déjà mouillé non plus et le
courroux de france fhf a ouais je fais
lula moi je vais rentrer chez moi me
sécher tu vas